sie bewarfen die polizei mit steinen
zündeten feuerwerkskörper und stürmen
das parlamentsgebäude
die polizei wehrt sich mit tränengas
auch knüppel sollen eingesetzt worden
sein
dramatische szenen aus der nacht in der
serbischen hauptstadt belgrad
schon der dritte abend in folge in der
friedlicher protest in pure gewalt
umschlägt
unter die demonstranten mischen sich
dieses mal auch gewaltbereite hooligans
und serbische nationalisten die erneuten
corona maßnahmen der regierung die
zunächst der auslöser der proteste waren
sei nur ein grund sagen die
demonstranten
die meisten versuchen es friedlich wir
sitzen ja heute in einem akt der
rebellion auch wenn manche damit nicht
einverstanden sind aber das bedeutet
nicht dass unser protest so weitergehen
wird und wir immer nur rumsitzen aber
wir glauben ein wenig passive aggression
ist der weg um voranzukommen
viele serben haben genug von
vetternwirtschaft und der regierung die
zunehmend autokratisch handelt die
proteste richten sich verstärkt gegen
den präsident alexander vujic
nationalisten werfen ihm nun auch verrat
vor weil er nach der
deutsch-französischen vermittlung neuen
gesprächen mit dem kosovo zustimmte es
ist eine neue form der gewalt die die
serbische hauptstadt überschattet ja
also wenn wir diese bilder nicht
eingefangen hätten ich würde selbst
nicht glauben zugeschaltet ist mir jetzt
mein kollege peter wilke peter erstmal
die frage wie geht's dir dann ist noch
alles dran bei dir ja ist noch alles
dran es war hier gestern abend wirklich
eine entladung der absoluten gewalt war
echt unglaublich und ist wirklich
unglaublich viel war dass es im
vergleich zum vorabend am
donnerstagabend als noch alles friedlich
spielt als sich die demonstranten sogar
insassen und zeigen wir wollen nicht
gewaltig werden wir wollen einfach nur
demonstrieren wir wollen gegen den
präsidenten laut werden und auch getanzt
haben das war gestern hier komplett
anders die stimmung war von anfang an
viel aggressiver und wie wir gehört
haben und dann mischten sich dann nach
und nach auf nationalisten serbische
nationalisten und hooligans darunter
ermutigend sorgten dann letztendlich für
den gewaltausbruch für den sturm auf das
parlament man kann auf diese enorme
gewalt hier direkt neben mir sehen an
der straße wie sie hier versucht haben
oder es dann noch geschafft haben dollar
aus dem boden heraus zu reißen nur um
steine zu haben die man dann auf die
polizisten speisen konnte also das war
ihr gestern wirklich klasse
oh ja das sehe ich auch also die straße
sieht ganz schön übel aus peter wer hat
denn da genau demonstriert was das schon
angerissen aber jetzt vielleicht noch
mal kurz zusammengefasst
ja das ist gestern wieder deutlich
geworden diese proteste das ist eine
mischung aus ganz vielen verschiedenen
gruppen die zusammen kommen und eine
wirklich klare linie gibt es nicht es
geht von ganzem ganz linken politischen
spektrum über die mitte bis hin zu den
nationalisten von den begleitern die
nationalisten nutzten dann gestern auch
diese bühne hier um den kriegsverbrecher
mladic zu feiern der heute vor 25 jahren
über 8000 menschen in srebrenica
umgebracht hat und ja und dazu kommen
dann die hooligans die scheinbar nur auf
der suche nach gewalt sind und es gibt
keine wirklich klar erkennbare linie
gestern wurde das erste mal hier einen
zettel verteilt auf denen die großen
ziele der friedlichen demonstranten zu
erkennen sind die fordern unter anderem
echt eine verbesserung des gesundheits
system hier in der kroner krise und dass
die polizeigewalt die vor allen dingen
am dienstag oder mittwoch zu sehen war
ein inder peter mainz so wird es heute
weiter gehen wird es heute weitere
gewalt geben ich meine es ist ja recht
trügerisch hinter dir sieht es aus als
wäre wieder ganz normaler alltag
ja das ist das können die hier in
belgrad wirklich echt gut das haben wir
schon mehrmals gemerkt dass sobald die
gewalt hier ausbricht wird geht die
polizei stark dagegen vor vertreibt die
demonstranten und kurz danach kommt die
straßenreinigung macht wieder alles
sauber und am nächsten tage sind kannst
du mal raus als wenn nichts gewesen wäre
bis auf ein paar schäden ja ob es jetzt
zu gewalt kommen wird das kann man nicht
genau wissen eins ist klar die
friedlichen proteste werden auf jeden
fall auch in den nächsten tagen
weitergehen weil die menschen wollen
sich nicht unterkriegen lassen
die menschen wollen sich auch von diesen
hooligans den ausschreitungen abspalten
und zeigen wir sind friedlich und ja wir
wollen veränderungen